perso si le le consensus américain entre
les républicains et les démocrates
maintenant il est clair que le résultat
de cette élection ça doit être
l'élimination de donald trump qui est un
danger absolu à la fois je crois pour
les états unis
bien sûr mais aussi pour la planète
entière on alors sa victoire reste
encore une hypothèse bien sûr a su alors
en me parlant d'une épopée il a jugé
notamment durant sa campagne il l'a
répété plusieurs fois que le
réchauffement climatique était un
canular et même une connerie là dit il
vous fait peur bien sûr aussi sur ces
sujets là mais vous savez il est
personne vous avez enough qui est un
sénateur qui d'ailleurs dirige le comité
sur l'environnement et l'énergie au
sénat qui a dit que le réchauffement
climatique c'était d'un complot que les
écologistes
c'était le troisième reich que le giec
donc le groupe des scientifiques
c'était la gestapo vous avez un
représentant au congrès qui lui aussi a
des responsabilités chez les plus
républicains et qui allie de toute façon
il ne peut pas y avoir d'élévation du
niveau de la mer liée aux dérèglements
climatiques puisque dieu a promis que le
déluge était terminée donc on a une base
climato-sceptiques extrêmement puissante
aux états unis mais derrière ce
climato-scepticisme là c'est évidemment
depuis des années vous savez le
financement des campagnes américaines ou
les lobbys les entreprises pétrolières
extrêmement présente le charbon le
pétrole sont extrêmement présenter y
compris les entreprises françaises qui
financent les campagnes américaines au
congrès comme au sénat et vous pouvez
regarder les chiffres vous avez par eva
vous avez angie qui ont été financés aux
états unis des entreprises et des
candidats des râteaux sceptiques
d'accord et on le sait aussi
hillary clinton est en partie financée
victoire départ va par les entreprises
de ce qu'on appelle donc le secteur où
le lobby pétrolier ce n'est pas vrai
c'est un vrai danger pour la démocratie
bernie sanders mais ça sert toujours
marché comme ça
non ça n'a pas toujours marché comme ça
vous avez eu depuis notamment sous bill
clinton
un relâchement complet des systèmes de
financement aux états unis heureusement
ces dernières années avec obama il ya eu
plus de transparence
mais on n'a pas cassé ce modèle de
financement qui fait que le congrès
comme la chambre des représentants
l'ensemble du congrès et quand même tenu
par les grands lobbys industrie alors un
mot sur hillary clinton bas même si vous
votez pas pour elle vous voteriez pas
pour elle vous espérez sa victoire
contre donald optionnel n'est pas une
climat sceptiques revendiqué mais quand
même j'ai vu qu'elle avait critiqué des
organisations comme greenpeace que vous
avez vous même servi yannick jadot
elle a dénoncé leur incapacité à
discuter qu'est-ce que vous inspire l
écoute et hillary clinton les masques je
trouve terrible aujourd'hui finalement
dans la politique américaine donald
trump est détesté et il est extrêmement
dangereux mais le niveau de défiance
vis-à-vis d'hillary clinton est terrible
cela dit quand même beaucoup sur la
démocratie américaine où les deux
candidats en capacité de gagner sont des
personnes globalement mal aimés ou
détestés par 80% des américains c'est
considérable
maintenant je crois que aller moins
penchée sur la question de
l'environnement qu'a pu l'être obama a
pris quasiment pas parlé pas là n'a
quasiment pas parlé en même temps du
fait du succès de bernie sanders du fait
de l'évolution des partis démocrates du
fait de la présence des syndicats très
fort dans la campagne à la revue ses
positions sur le libre échange et
notamment sur la place des lobbys
pétroliers au sein de ces accords
transatlantique et il va falloir il va
falloir qu'elle ait le même courage
malgré le congrès que obama d'essayer
vous savez aux états unis le président
peut faire des décret passé par l'
agence de protection de l'environnement
et donc de contourner le congrès c'est
ce qui se passe sur le niveau d'émission
des centrales charbon des choses comme
ça il va falloir que les courages
d'accélérer les choses que les états
unis sont quand même très en retard
de ce point de vue un mot pour qualifier
trump c'est un fou je vais dire je sais
ça s'éteint c'est un fou dangereux je
veux dire quand vous écoutez ses
discours
quand vous voyez ce qu'il est capable de
porter comme n
dans la politique américaine ce qu'il
est capable de porter comme défiance
vis-à-vis de la démocratie ce qu'il
était capable de dire ou de faire sur
les femmes sur les américains d'origine
hispanique notamment c'est franchement
enfin ça serait un faux voilà sera
terrible allez première partie de
l'épreuve de vérité avec jean francis
pécresse le directeur de la rédaction de
radio classique qui nous rejoint bonsoir
en français bonsoir michel bonsoir ya un
morceau ou alors vous nous promettez une
écologie exaltante une écologie
pragmatique une écologie subversives
je vais vous vous expliquer enfin je
voudrais vous vous expliquer sur ces
trois termes en commençant peut-être par
le subversif
quand on voit l'état de notre pays que
ce soit en matière évidemment d'énergie
d'agriculture d'affaissement de notre
démocratie de 2,2 de renforcement des
discriminations je crois que les
françaises et les français savent qu'il
va y avoir des changements profonds à
feurs dans la société
trop souvent les responsables politiques
qu'à chaque complexité cache la
complexité le temps des réponses aux
crises que nous traversons être
subversif pour moi c'est affirmer la
radicalité des transformations que nous
avons engagées pour à la fois que notre
avenir ne soit pas assombries par le
dérèglement climatique l'épuisement des
ressources
l'airé l'explosion des maladies
chroniques les extinction des espèces
tout ça fera que si on n'agit pas
l'avenir sera sombre donc être subversif
c'est oser la radicalité des changements
engagés et si je dis que je vais
crédible les pragmatiques
si je peux me permettre de poursuivre
son décret contradictoires et non
justement c'est de fixer un horizon de
transformation mais d'accompagner les
françaises et les français tous les
jours dans cette phase de transformation
bon concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement que ça veut dire que
quand vous avez le macaron
quand vous voulez matin quand vous allez
appuyer sur l'interrupteur pour éclairer
chez vous et bien cette électricité là
elle ne renforce pas le risque nucléaire
est elle ne renforce pas
le dérèglement climatique elle vient
d'énergies renouvelables elle vient de
vos économies d'énergie et donc dès
votre premier geste vous agissez pour la
planète et vous agissez pour des emplois
qui sont situés dans votre territoire
quand vous allez passer au petit
déjeuner quand vous allez passer au
petit déjeuner vous allez je sais pas ce
que vous petit déjeuner peu importe
imaginons vous preniez des céréales et
une étude très récente de générations
futures cas montré qu'on avait un
cocktail de perturbateurs endocriniens
de pesticides dans ce que vous mangez ce
qui fait que la france est le pays de la
convivialité en matière alimentaire
devient un pays où l'alimentation
devient suspecte est bien là vous
mangerez des choses qui sont aussi
bonnes pour du point de vue du goût pour
la santé et après vous allez prendre un
transport collectif qui eut une voiture
que vous partagez qui sera peu
polluantes qui sera intelligente qui
vous emmènera à votre boulot parce que
l'écologie aura créé du boulot pour vous
à l'échelle des territoires et je peux
accompagner comme ça c'est le monde
rêvant demande existe déjà mais moi ce
que je sais que ce soit pour toutes les
françaises et pour tous les français
donc ça c'est pragmatique exaltant parce
que je veux créer de l'enthousiasmé dans
ce pays ce pays est submergé par les
déclinistes par les artisans du
renoncement par les prêcheurs de haine
moi je veut semer l'espoir je fais une
campagne qui montre qu'on a des
ressources extraordinaires dans le pays
des compétences incroyable est que si on
les met en mouvement et que si on laisse
toutes les autres énergies se mettre en
mouvement
notre pays sera riche de son dynamisme
est ce que ça veut dire par exemple que
vous tournerez le dos à une forme
d'écologie punitive une écologie fiscal
par exemple mais quoi qu'il en dise
qu'alizé non non donc il y aura des mois
ce que je veux faire c'est pas une
excuse ccvg en prime l'écologie punitive
aujourd'hui sur la taxe poids lourds ce
sont les citoyens qui la paye celles qui
sont punis
vous avez remarqué que vous et moi on
est en train de perdre quand on est en
région ile-de-france 20 mois d'espérance
de vie du fait de la pollution de l'air
qui est puni c'est le
l'usagé avec son automobile qui paye lui
la l'entretien des routes plutôt que les
poids lourds c'est tous ceux qui veulent
se balader en la campagne comme en ville
avec des transports collectifs qui n'ont
pas eu cette taxe poids lourds pour
financer les transports collectifs
mais quand je parle de fiscalité pour
moi le modèle c'est le transfert s'est
pas plus de fiscalité
c'est le transfert de 5 points de pib de
fiscalité travail vers la fiscalité
écolo je la faisais réduire la fiscalité
sur le travail c'est agir pour le bien
le travail c'est un bien moins de
fiscaliser s'est développé ce bien en
revanche les pollutions les
consommations d'énergie lassus le
gaspillage
il faut ce sont des mots il faut taxer
les pollueurs c'est ça bien sûr mes
contacts - travail et policiers pour
l'heure donc c'est pas plus de fiscalité
c'est un transfert de fiscalité comment
on passe de notre modèle actuel où le
nucléaire assure 75 % de la production
d'énergie électrique à un modèle où vous
passerez à quoi 50 % en mai l'ademe
l'asvel ont fait les bric en charge
qu'elle se question l'a dit qu'on peut
passer aux petits cantons sont
renouvelables
votre solution 100 renouvelable à
l'horizon à quel horizon à l'ademe 10 à
l'horizon 2050 c'est un bon horizons
pour être à 100% renouvelable
mais regardez il ya des écologistes ou
qui disent qu'ils affirment manière ex
extrêmement clair et très sérieuse et
très argumenté que cette transition vers
des énergies renouvelables on ne peut
pas la faire
si on abandonne trop vite notre filière
nucléaire person veux beaucoup au
nucléaire c'est une énergie propre au
renard nous n avons pas de co2 elle et
elle aimait aller mais elle aimait quand
même du co2 parce que vous avez ainsi
que de production et regardez regardez
la situation du nucléaire dans notre
pays
on a aujourd'hui du fait de notre
obsession du nucléaire du fait de du
fait que devant une telle concentration
de l'origine de notre électricité
regardez on a plein de réacteurs qui
sont en difficulté et on a là où les
incidents sont en train de se multiplier
notre addiction au nucléaire la preuve
et on saura les rangs les ont placés les
biennales par an et c'est cette énergie
c'est bien la preuve aujourd'hui
une énergie propre c'est bien la preuve
qu'il faut construire ce remplacement
jamais dit qu'on allait fermer les
centrales nucléaire demain bien sûr
qu'il va falloir quand même un peu
investir aussi pour répondre aux
exigences de l'autorité de surpoids mais
alors un les exigences de sûreté
nucléaire bien sûr mais on est quand
même regarder la situation d'edf 37
milliards de dette
un mur d'investissement d'au moins 100
milliards selon la cour des comptes
vous avez un engagement de près de 20
milliards sur hinkley point qui les
opèrent en grande bretagne vous avez les
déchets que rien que le simple le site
de bure envisagée pour l'enfouissement
que nous dénonçons c'est au moins 30
milliards et edf a osé monsieur lévy a
osé dire le démantèlement c'est pas pour
ce siècle
edf existe depuis 60 ans
le nucléaire c'est 40 ans et monsieur
lévy dit ah bah non c'est le 22ème
siècle où on commencera à agir pour le
démantèlement parce qu'on peut pas le
financer est-ce qu'on peut pas faire
comme les autres pays intelligent qui
est d'investir massivement sur les
énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez le
photovoltaïque l'éolien terrestre sont
des énergies qui sont plus compétitives
beaucoup plus compétitifs que le
nucléaire est à chaque fois que vous
investissez un euro dans ces énergies là
vous créer trois à quatre fois plus
d'emplois que dans le nucléaire
c'est ce que font les autres et pourquoi
est ce que nous on serait pardon et qui
sont instables par définition puisque on
n'a pas devant tout le temps et qu'on
n'a pas je suis d'accord mais y'a pas
que cyril et qu'on a un réseau européen
qu'elles sont on ya 130 ans commence on
a un réseau en europe et un juge répond
on à un réseau européen d'électricité le
leb la base y compris des énergies
renouvelables en france et l'hydraulique
ça n'est pas un intermittent c'est la
biomasse ça n'est pas intermittents si
on développe les énergies marines ça
n'est pas intermittents et quand vous
avez un réseau européen
vous avez entre les grands ce que ce que
font les grands pays modernes ceux où la
situation économique est bien meilleure
ou la situation du chômage est bien
meilleure la leaf hommes de leo servir
sur la main mais par simplement le même
tous les pays nordiques sont sur ce
développement là que tout ils font de
l'éolien offshore
c'est très c'est peu intermittents vous
faites du solaire qui est de plus en
plus efficace et on vous avez des
sociétés à grenoble qui sont recorman du
monde
2 2 l'efficacité du photovoltaïque et au
pire on vous écoute la 19 % de leur
production trouve en dehors de
transition énergétique la feuille de
route que s'était fixé le gouvernement
en 2012 elle traîne elle est trop long
comme objectifs n'ont pas été atteints
ben oui parce qu'il ya un langage esnam
ça reste un bas alors qu'il faut fermer
un coup d'oeil aux rites et fessenheim
après c'est budget le tricastin faut que
vous avez les centrales qui sont
extrêmement en difficulté à g et combien
vous habite à son l'accord qu'on avait
passé et le le cheminement de le
cheminement dans le cheminement c'est
faut fermer 25 réacteurs d'ici 2025
valérie factory bien sûr précise
lanthier mais que la moitié cc mais
c'est l'engagement de françois hollande
la feuille de route 50% d'électricité
d'origine
si si c'est le sait ce qui est sorti du
débat public sur la loi de transition en
hd le problème c'est que vous regardez
pas 25 centrales jeudi 25 réacteurs cinq
réacteurs mais pour m j'ai dit vingt cas
non si je ne suis je suis arrivé ici je
suis quand ils se disent le problème
c'est que ce qui est sorti le 27 octobre
la feuille de route du gouvernement sur
la planification pluriannuelle de
l'énergie ne traduis absolument pas en
actes l'engagement du président de
république
donc on est on est un pays qui a lutté
au niveau européen pour casser la
dynamique des énergies renouvelables
justement pour défendre son nucléaire
avec la grande bretagne et qui en france
ne traduit pas dans les faits même
l'engagement du président de la
république
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a quelques
soucis avec ce gouvernement sur un
chantier encore une fois l'allemagne ces
quatre cent mille emplois sur les
énergies renouvelables
est ce qu'on peut se payer le luxe de ne
pas créer c'est en baroeul a surtout
noté les autres chantiers celui de
l'aéroport de notre dame des landes
alors il ya une décision de justice qui
est attendu je vous propose d'écouter ce
que disait nicolas sarkozy ce matin sur
cette antenne
sur public sénat à propos de ce sujet on
l'écouté vous réagissez il est surtout
un tri ferrand d'hommes et pour moi le
référendum c'est capital un référendum
cas dit il faut faire cet aéroport donc
je ne sais pas ce que représente cette
population qui occupe en toute
illégalité
plusieurs dizaines d'hectares dans la
région pays de la loire
je demanderai immédiatement l'expulsion
de ces gens dont une partie
appartiennent à l'it et l'extrême gauche
étrangères dont l'autre partie réside là
on se demande de quoi et vif
je peux vous mettre sur une piste ils
vivent de subventions payées avec les
cotisations des gens qui travaillent on
parle de bonne famille et ils disent
n'importe quoi
les adrets veut une grande partie de
ceux qui vivent sur place cultivent la
terre sont implantés sur la terre et
travaillent vivent du travail de la
terre donc monsieur sarkozy j'imagine
qu'il est il n'est pas totalement
bienvenue mais enfin s'il veut venir il
sera pas il sera évidemment protégés
bien et pouvoir venir mais vous avez vu
des policiers lyncher ratonner dans
témoignages vous avez des présidents
mais donnez-moi montrez moi une image de
policiers des chiens dressés les langues
qu on n'arrête pas de vous êtes vous
animé cette émission vous êtes
journaliste vous me dites il ya des
policiers qui ont été lynchées en
ukraine des langues
donnez moi une image d'un policier
lynché notre dame des landes
non mais là qu'est ce que je sais c'est
qu'il ya deux ans ce que je sais c'est
qu'il ya deux ans c'est un militant
écologiste qui a été tuée une zone à
6,26 fils et mamie zone où je demeure un
télévision ne vont même pas parmi ceux
ci on y va je suis j'y suis allé j'avais
l'année
est ce que vous êtes anivia tout
simplement moi j'ai fait partie du jeu
fait partie du comité national de
transition écologique c'est l'instance
de dialogue environnemental installé par
ce gouvernement il ya le medef il ya
l'association des maires de france
l'association des régions de france les
parlementaires les associations donc et
l'état quand cette consultation locale a
été proposée par manuel valls fidèles à
l'unanimité à l'unanimité on a dit non
les pros aéroports comme les anti
aéroport à l'unanimité le projet de
consultations locales proposée par
manuel valls a été rejeté par le
commission la colle
comité national de transition écologique
ce qui se passe maintenant à nantes
c'est ce que nous disons depuis des
années ce que va traiter le tribunal le
tribunal a muselé le tribunal de grande
instance
c'est de dire est ce qu a dit le
rapporteur la rapporteur public
c'est ce l'ailé les a été d'autorisation
des travaux sont incompatibles avec la
loi loi sur l'eau loi sur les espèces
protégées et ce qu'elle a dit ce que
nous disons depuis le début de cette
lutte elle dit il est inconcevable que
ce projet que l'alternative qui est une
obligation il ya la légalité qui va
peut-être être contestées si ldc la
légitimité c'est elle en effet random
locale mais je viens de vous dire que la
consultation
vous savez on nous l'avons dénoncée aux
jo 1 de la consultation
je vous ai dit que même les pros
aéroport notre dame des landes dans le
cadre du dialogue environnemental ce qui
doit justement décidé de ce type de
processus elle avait rejeté à
l'unanimité
la maman verts europe ecologie les verts
mais on a toujours dit que on a toujours
dit que sa situation va faire était
biaisé dès le départ vous contestez la
raison vous savez qu'on a contesté la
question on avait en même temps quand
même
c'est quand même le bazar on avait en
même temps madame royal qui commandite
et un rapport qui disait comme la
rapporteur public travaillons sur
l'aéroport actuel dernier lorsque vous
voyez que dans un livre de confidences
françois hollande lui-même dit qu'il
pense que cet aéroport ne se fera pas ça
serait bien qu'ils le disent une fois
bien qu'il ait une fois qu'une fois
devant vous et moi en tant que citoyens
intelligents on essaye de lettres puis
plutôt que de parler à des journalistes
et de dire l'inversé quand il passe
c'est en vo médias que y profite je
l'espère de la décision de justice pour
mettre fin à cette histoire absurde qui
n'a que trop duré dion est ce que sur
ces questions écologiques et
environnementales est ce que vous voyez
en france l'équivalent d'un donald trump
et je suis très inquiet que le parti
les républicains quand j'ai entendu les
déclarations de luc chatel de ce que
fait wauquiez dans sa région et de ce
qu'il dit de nicolas sarkozy devienne à
l'image du pis en pologne et des
républicains aux états unis deviennent
un parti anti écolo c
pas seulement un parti qui arrête de
parler de la protection de
l'environnement
je suis très inquiet et je regrette
profondément sarkozy avait un gros coup
avec avec le grenelle vous les traitez
pas de fuku tout à l'heure comme donald
trump
non attendez quand même une différence
d'accord est à la glace est noté ba1
je regrette surtout des membres sur les
inquiet je suis très inquiet par
l'évolution des républicains sur ce
sujet très bien merci
jean-francis voit la deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
lucile malandain notre consoeur de l'
agence france presse qui nous rejoint il
est prof de vérité avec l'eye fi
bonsoir l'ue c'est lé mont saint michel
pour ces ados alors la question qu'on
voulait vous vous posez plus peu plus
politique
c est ce que votre candidature qui
décide et depuis hier soir ne rajoute t
elle pas un peu plus encore de division
à gauche je crois pas est ce que je vois
aujourd'hui de ce qui se passe au sein
du parti socialiste profondément fait ne
m'intéresse pas on a à droite on en
parlait les règlements de comptes du
sarkozysme on a à gauche
les règlements de comptes du hollandisme
donc ils sont tous en train de s'étriper
sur ce quinquennat
ce qu'ils ont fait au début ce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait moi je veux parler aux
françaises et aux français de leur vie
quotidienne de l'avenir de la planète et
de leur avenir
donc le savez même ans en 2000 on parle
toujours du 20 heures du 21 avril 2011
après lionel jospin quand il était
interrogé sur la division de la gauche
il avait eu cette phrase qui est de dire
oui évidemment taubira tout ça c'était
pas une bonne idée de l'avoir poussé à
être candidat parce qu'il n'a pas
empêché d'être candidate
mais il a dit il y avait une candidature
qui était légitime c'est celle des
écologistes parce que le projet
écologiste n'est pas le projet
socialiste
donc ça veut en 2012 la gauche les
choses ont évolué ça fait quand même une
quinzaine d'années et 2002 et la
dernière fois vous aviez passé un accord
avec les socialistes ont certes on n'en
n'avait pas reçu beaucoup de
satisfaction c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
enfin beaucoup de lui pour autant ça
vous a d'abord aidé à avoir un groupe à
l'assemblée et au sénat
et est ce que c'est ce que tous les
socialistes sont à mettre dans la même
dans le même temps moi je moi je parle
du dernier socialiste et de la politique
je vous avais passé bien sûr je parle du
parti socialiste parle de ce
gouvernement
je quitte le parti socialiste qui
officiellement soutient ce gouvernement
et ce gouvernement qui est piloté par un
premier ministre et sous la haute
direction d'un président de la
république donc je vois la politique lui
même
en 2012 la gauche avec les écologistes
présents à tous les 1er tour avec les
villes les départements les régions
l'assemblée le sénat la présidence est
donc le gouvernement
depuis c'est défaite après défaite ce ne
sont pas les écologistes qui sont
responsables de cette défaite c'est la
politique qui a été menée qui est
responsable et en même temps ils ne
restent pas certains socialistes qui
serait peut-être plus frais que bible
mais ils sont fréquentables mais qui
rejoignent ma candidature je les
accueille avec un immense plaisir ce que
je sais qu'il ya plein de socialistes à
prix ronds leur karl inverse
oui mais non moi je suis pas là moi je
suis j'ai été désignée par la primaire
et que des écologistes
je suis pas là moi pour sauver
l'appareil du parti socialiste parce que
quand même je me souviens c'était payé
au début de l'année
yannick jadot vous aviez d'ailleurs
pétition dans libération avec d'autres
réclament et bien sûr de la gauche
et bien aujourd'hui 2 et que la gauche
et des écologistes est aujourd'hui la
socialiste aurélie filipetti et bien
vous propose de vous joindre justement à
ces primaires c'est et vendredi c'était
vendredi dernier sur public sénat
j'aimerais que le futur candidat des
verts participent à la primaire de la
gauche parce que ça nous enrichirait et
notamment sur les questions
environnementales on a absolument besoin
et aussi bien michèle rivasi que yannick
jadot sont des experts en matière
environnementale bah moi je pense que la
gauche allait forte oui quand elle et
quand elle est rassemblé dans sa
diversité
ça veut dire pas d'union au forceps ça
veut dire le respect des sensibilités
des uns et des autres et surtout de la
place pour leurs idées alors les
de rassembler la gauche on respectera
votre sensibilité
oui enfin je bous le point c'est que je
pense que l'écologie sortira de cette
primaire parce qu'il y aura des
candidats qui se disent les écologistes
dans cette primaire elle sortira de
cette primaire aussi essorer qu'elle
l'est dans ce gouvernement quand le
pouvoir alors là c'est une attaque
directe de monsieur venue de roger
ils agissent comme vous mais il abat
part exactement pareil en effet papa on
n'a pas la même idée de la stratégie
politique des combats à mener à des
conversions et l'engagement des lilas il
a des convictions et d engagement
simplement aujourd'hui soutient un
gouvernement qui tous les jours tourne
le dos à l'écologie donc je m'interroge
sur la force de ses convictions par
rapport à ça mais sur la question qui
était posée quand j'ai défendu la
primaire de toutes les règles et gauche
et des écologistes
l'idée c'était qu'il ya un grand débat
citoyen que de ce grand débat citoyen
nes un socle commun de réponse aux
problèmes des français et que lié à
l'issue de cette primaire des contrats
de gouvernement entre les différentes
sensibilités
hélas la primaire qui est une partie une
primaire du parti socialiste à la façon
de 2011 va sortir un candidat qui
aujourd'hui alors peut-être ce sera
hollande peut-être ce sera mon amour
j'en sais rien du tout de leur histoire
est ce que ça veut dire que ça oui et
stablement trop star donc mais écoutez
écoutez arnaud montebourg il ya encore
une semaine
ils soutenaient notre dame des landes il
dit il faut faire immédiatement
l'aéroport il soutient nucléaire il
soutient le diesel
je n'ai pas vu macron je sais pas si les
participants je vois hollande valls ou
tous les autres qui potentiellement y
participent
soutenir l'agriculture la plus intensive
désolé ce n'est pas le logiciel écolo la
démarche du parti communiste de tia
laurent qui a fait un grand débat qui a
organisé un grand questionnaire et qui
aujourd'hui présente une plateforme de
propositions serait il vous a pas
échappé qu'on a des différences forte
avec le parti communiste jean luc
mélenchon alors lui alors ils disent que
vous je suis pas là pour sauver les
appareils politiques de gauche qui sont
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté mais je
suis là pour porter un projet écologiste
veut redonner du sens et de la cohérence
à la politique dans ce pays
donc je veux pas jouer des accords
d'appareil pour un moment se dire c'est
le sauve-qui-peut généralisé et comment
va tirer notre épingle
est-ce que si vous voulez pas vous
retirer à leur profit est ce que par
exemple pourrait servir de trait d'union
de dénominateur commun est ce qu'il ya
encore quelque chose
l'espagne est allés fracturer et donc
moi je veux je veux pas construire des
alliances sur des logiques d'appareil je
veux réconcilier les françaises et les
français au sur la politique autour du
projet écologiste
je veux leur redonner espoir au tour du
projet écologiste et vous me parliez de
jean-luc mélenchon
évidemment il a progressé sur la
question environnementale c'est
incontestable mais moi et le
nationalisme et l'étatisme pour moi sont
des réponses incompatible avec la mise
en oeuvre des bonnes solutions moi je
vous renforcer le pouvoir des citoyens
et moi je combats toutes les dictatures
je considère pas un moment que poutine
est plus sympa que obama parce que je
suis anti américain je pense que le
coeur du projet écologiste c'est la
démocratie et que là dessus on a
quelques divergences ça vous a pas
échappé alors l ego semblait
effectivement il réconciliables selon le
matin jean pas aux partis de gauche qui
sont des gens très sympa très engagé et
tout ça même le candidat jean luc
mélenchon a plein de qualités
je parlais d'un gauche en général cela
vous êtes très sévère depuis un moment
mais maintenant on va être sévère avec
europe ecologie les verts il s'est
peut-être actions passées alors voilà
partis exemple qu'à plus d'argent qu'à
perdu je crois la moitié de ces
militants ces cinq dernières années la
faute notamment à l'un d'entre vous
vendez votre fric et encore il ya peu
jean vincent placé sous l'accusation de
michèle rivasi qui a fait cette
déclaration et qui a fait campagne
contre euro et qui vous soutient tout à
fait loyalement désormais à l'intérieur
de notre parti a des gens qui ont plutôt
privilégier leur carrière personnelle
leurs ambitions personnelles mais les
gens reconnaîtront leurs petits en
quelque sorte et que ça soit pas notre
projet qu'a été fédérateur des gens
comme jean vincent placé ou à de rugy
qui ont préféré avoir des postes
ministériels ou emma emmanuelle cosse
qui était notre secrétaire national et
qu'après préféré être ministre
justement des logements plutôt que de
rester dans notre parti pour le
construire les développer alors c'est la
course aux places qui a tué l'écologie
politique bien sûr bien sûr qu'il ya eu
un cirque des aventures personnelles au
sein d'europe écologie
ces dernières années et qu'effectivement
notamment les personnes que site
michèle rivasi qui n'a pas fait campagne
contre moi sont à vos côtés
voilà un contrôle et donc effectivement
ils ont fait beaucoup de mal
est ce que à l'image de l'écologie
politique j'en suis toujours
terriblement peiné par ce que je vois
les militants je vois les élus locaux
qui protège notre santé qui protège
l'eau qui met en place et transports
collectifs qui ont fait cas pas de gaz
de schiste dans notre pays qui a pas de
gm et qui se voient souvent un peu
bousculé par l'image qu'on a pu donner
ces dernières années et c'est bien mon
projet cette idée de sortir de ce cirque
là c'est pour ça que je suis une ligne
l'écologie crédible une écologie et mab
ni culpabiliser ni punitive au monde en
discuter tout à l'heure et un peu de
moins est ce que moi c'est madame cette
image cette image d'un parti donc très
fracturée n'ayant plus de fait des
finances très en forme ça ne va pas
jouer sur votre campagne en termes de
parrainage en termes de financement de
candidat ment et enfin peut-être en
termes aussi d' équipe et de
réconciliation possible à l'intérieur
alors il va parce que vous suivez de
près les écologistes vous savez que
depuis le début j'ai rassemblé toutes
les sensibilités de ce mouvement et y
reçoit l'image de toutes les candidats
et le candidat réunit se projetant dans
la campagne
ça fait longtemps que notre mouvement
n'avait pas été aussi rassemblé et uni
lorsqu'il sait que sinon il est en
danger et met cette primaire il y avait
plus de votants à l'extérieur d'europe
écologie qu'à l'intérieur des queues de
l'écologie donc ma candidature et la
candidature de l'écologie politique
alors oui ça va être la course aux
parrainages
gilles va falloir travailler très
sérieusement y compris parce qu'une
partie du financement public vous savez
en dépend donc il va falloir travailler
très sérieusement et il va falloir et
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai lancé déjà
une collecte de dons sur avec jade au
point fr pour justement aider à financer
cette campagne parce que et c'est bien
d'avoir une campagne et je la veux
exaltante mais il faut quand même
quelques sous quelques mois et que ça
puisse se développer ce que
dans ce
dans cette dans cette union que vous
avez montré hier excusez moi cécile
duflot n'a pas pris la parole hier soir
alors que les autres candidates
malheureuses avait pris la parole
n'était pas là bon est-ce que vous lui
avez parlé hier soir est-ce que menacer
on s'échange échangé des textos
cécile duflot a du talent on a besoin
d'être dans cette campagne comme on a
besoin de tous deux les figures et des
militants d'europe écologie est bon à
l'extérieur
nicolas hulot et nicolet alors termine
sur cécile duflot et ce qu'elle peut on
a échangé avec nicolas hulot il falloir
prendre le temps y compris de le
convaincre que cette candidature
écologiste que cette campagne écologiste
et celle qui s'inscrit le plus près dans
sa volonté de réouvrir toutes les portes
de l'écologie politique et de parler à
l'ensemble de la société pas simplement
aux écologistes mais de parler à
l'ensemble de la société pour l'instant
donc on va te soutenir officiellement
coûté ça tout ça mais j'ai été désigné
j'ai été désigné hier donnons le temps
au temps très bien alors un chiffre pour
conclure telle est votre ambition
sachant qu'il s'agit de battre le 2d
réguler je les ai un pour cent de 2002
ne dis pas ça comme ça avec cette voie
avec un cinq ans je voulais dire un peu
taquiné joli ce que j'ai dit vous savez
en 2009 quand on a fait europe ecologie
on n'a pas dit on va gagner on va
écraser tout le monde hein dis on fera
de 10 plus x quand nicolas hulot
candidats potentiels à l'élection
présidentielle était testée il était à
10 plus et ben moi ça veut dire qu'il ya
il ya un espace politique pour
l'écologie qui est autour de dollars de
10%
c'est l'espace politique et je veux
conquérir avec fougue et enthousiasme et
détermination allez on vous donne encore
l'occasion de vous exprimer pour
convaincre les faux là
avec maintenant mais si votre audience
avec mes temps mickaël szames skis
succède à notre ami lucille
voilà mes 4 à metz depuis vixen est avec
nous bon sens michel bonsoir monsieur
jadot bonsoir monsieur qui êtes vous
monsieur g parce que vous êtes un ancien
de greenpeace sa part ça vous êtes quoi
aujourd'hui un homme politique à
professionnels de la politique où vous
êtes resté encore un activiste je suis
un homme politique j'assume parfaitement
de ne plus de l'écologie associative je
suis de l'écologie politique
j'ai un mandat de député européen depuis
2009 dont je suis un homme politique je
suis pas un professionnel professionnels
à professionnels de la politique
non parce que enfin si vous voulez c'est
mon activité principale
donc c'est une forme de profession mais
j'ai eu beaucoup de vies avant celle
d'être député européen
j'ai travaillé au burkina faso j'ai
travaillé au bangladesh
j'ai fait dix ans de solidarité
internationale j'ai travaillé dans les
associations comme vous l'avez dit j'ai
dirigé les campagnes de greenpeace
donc je ne suis pas attaché à la
politique plus que ça
et donc j'ai j'adore ce que je fais je
me bats pour ce que je fais mais je ne
me sens pas dépendant de la politique je
suis pas passée je suis pas prêt à
passer n'importe quel compromis pour
conserver un mandat ou pour en obtenir
un autre
est ce que quand on a un problème de
notoriété un déficit de notoriété
puisque eva joly elle a capitalisé sur
son nom c'était il ya cinq ans vous avez
capitalisé sur quoi sur la campagne
qu'on va mener sur nos tables on partait
de zéro en quelque sorte à la fois vous
êtes taquin non fabre ont écouté la
regarder j'ai fait une vidéo sur le site
a été de 3 millions de fans al adha 3
millions mais c'est le million
on a des millions un million maintenant
vous et non mais regardez regardez sur
le vol rien de semble regarder sur le
site du nouvel obs 2 millions ça fait
plus d'un an qu'il saurait russe plus
plus là à l'instant même puisque on
regarde effectivement c'était alors un
souvenir mémorable pour vous
effectivement c'était le 27 octobre
dernier lorsque vous avez poussé ce coup
de gueule au parlement européen donc
contre l'accord de libre échange négocié
alors avec le canada on vous regarde
vous parler au nom des salariés sur le
c'est à écouter les salariés ils ne
veulent pas dû c'est à vous prétendez
parler au nom des consommateurs
écoutez les ils ne veulent pas du ceta
les consommateurs vous prétendez parler
au nom des citoyens européens
et qu'est ce que vous leur direz
messieurs juncker quand la commission
fera enfin son boulot sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens et que
bailleur et monsanto ferons condamner
l'europe pour les mesures prises qu'est
ce que vous direz monsieur tough aux
citoyens européens
quand l'europe refera son boulot de
leadership sur le climat et que ce
seront les firmes canadiennes des sables
bitumineux et du pétrole et des gaz de
schiste qui attaqueront l'europe alors
avec ce modèle européen que vous portez
de circulation sans entrave des biens
des marchandises des investissements
mais des barbelés des murs et des camps
pour les personnes vous déroulé le tapis
rouge de l'extrême droite et de tous les
nationalismes ayez le courage d'aller
devant la cour européenne de justice sur
le ceta soyez cohérents avec vos propos
aller devant la cour européenne
enfin que vous tenez votre spot de
campagne il va falloir parler d'autre
chose que du ceta mais c'est un sujet
important parce qu'il ils détermineront
la marque aussi c'est le ton bien sûr un
des campagnes sur ce ton là on peut pas
faire ça tout le temps là c'est vous
avez une minute si vous faites un
meeting à ce rythme là vous vous heurtez
vous sortez fatigué non mais c'est de la
conviction c'est de la sincérité c'est
vrai il se passe regarder comment la
mondialisation est en train de perturber
l'ensemble de nos sociétés c'est quand
même ça bouscule tout le monde et c'est
vrai que dans cette mondialisation où on
sait plus qui gouverne on sait plus qui
décide c'est l'opacité
c'est quand même une place
extraordinaire pour des firmes
multinationales qui pour le coup ne
servent pas l'environnement au contraire
le détruit vous avez aujourd'hui des
accords qui veulent non pas faire du
libre échange le commerce est déjà très
libre avec le canada avec les états unis
mais qui veulent transférer le pouvoir
de décision de la règle de la norme à
des firmes avec la capacité d'attaquer
des états c'est totalement dingue que
vous faites votre cas que vous formulez
d'aller saisir la cour de vassieux
justice ou ibm est-ce que vous allez
passer aux actes parce que c'est là
dessus qu'on va vous attendez mais bien
sûr mais écoutez c'est faux que le
parlement la demande le peuple le
parlement wallon qui a résisté longtemps
sur cette affaire-là qui a été due cette
façon un moment un peu le renouveau de
la social démocratie en europe qu'on
n'attendait pas venir de belgique
kadi cette mondialisation libérale
peut-être qu'il faut arrêter les bêtises
de suivre les libéraux et les
conservateurs là dessus bon hollande l'a
pas aidé mais le spd en allemagne ne l'a
pas aidé donc magnette s'est retrouvé
tout seul dans cette affaire mais ce que
dit la cour constitutionnelle allemande
savez en allemagne la cour
constitutionnelle c'est au-dessus de la
bible c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
sérieux dit cet accord a priori est
anticonstitutionnelle c'est ce que
disent tous les juristes européens
c'est le débat qu'on a essayé d'avoir à
l'assemblée nationale et c'est le
gouvernement qui a bloqué ce débat à
l'assemblée nationale
ce que je dis j'essaye de porter ça au
niveau du parlement européen et ce
serait le courage de la france de le
faire c'est d'aller devant la cour
européenne de justice pour demander si
ce traité est conforme avec notre âme
avec notre sang sien cet accord faut le
rappeler - soit le premier ministre le
soutien et je regrette tous les éléments
je le regrette profondément mais ce que
je leur dis si c'est pas conforme avec
la constitution qu'est ce qu'on fait
bernard cazeneuve qui demande
l'ouverture d'un débat parlementaire sur
ce qu'on appelle le tfc le méga fichier
des données où on aura toutes les
données des français signe d'ouverture
de la part du ministre assez rétro
pédalage à tous les étages ah bon ah bah
écoutez ce truc qu'ils aient haussé de
le faire passer comme ça et puis vous
avez commencé à avoir des réactions au
sein du gouvernement est faux
reconnaître le maire vous reconnaître la
pugnacité d'axel le maire qui sur ces
sujets là et très bien donc raid de
l'agresseur
bah oui si vous voulez on est quand même
dans un système qui est totalement fou
vous avez la ministre en charge etc y
compris qui est très sensible sur ces
questions de libertés publiques et de
vie privée vous avez la cnil vous avez
beaucoup d'intervenants qui disent c'est
totalement dingue de faire ce fichier là
donc il faut arrêter par dix a fait ça à
la cne ne dis pas que c'est totalement
dingue avery attention ce que faure sûr
que ce que ces données privées tombe
entre des mains qui peut être
malveillantes c'est toujours le souci
des libertés et de la vie privée et des
libertés publiques liées à ce type de à
ce type de données donc il faut quand
même toujours rappeler qu'en démocratie
ce sont les citoyens qui contrôle l'état
ça n'est pas l'état qui contrôle les
citoyens comment est-ce que vous
qualifieriez aujourd'hui ce projet assez
petit c'est une erreur c'est une erreur
évidente puisque moi tous les experts
j'entends je suis pas un expert du
hacking tous les experts que j'entends
nous disent avoir un tel fichier
accessible par autant de services c'est
un système qui assez rapidement se fera
à quai et donc des données privées
seront potentiellement mal utilisé donc
il faut les mettre
est ce que vous avez réfléchi à des
actions vous pourriez mener pour lutter
contre ce fichier pour demander sa
suspension par le débat ça va être le
boulot de deux de l'assemblée notamment
qui va s'emparer je suis candidat à
l'élection présidentielle oui moi je
vous dis que je suis contre ce projet
mais je suis contre ce projet donc je ne
peux pas vous dire plus
maintenant je suis convaincu que nos
élus à l'assemblée au sénat vont faire
le boulot pour essayer de stopper ce
projet franchement à prévaloir
enseignements après l'état d'urgence
tout ça ça suffit autre sujet des
députés républicains souhaitent faire
destituer le président de la république
après ses propos dans le livre
un président ne devrais pas dire ça je
vous vois soufflé est ce que c'est
quelque chose on n'est pas préparé
si vous voulez je crois que
malheureusement pour lui
et oui pour françois hollande
moi j'ai l'impression françois hollande
c'est déjà le passé géant nadia
l'impression qu' il ne gouverne plus
pays que quand il parle au bout d'une
minute et demie vous arrêtez de
l'écouter c'est terrible parce que c'est
le président de la république que i là
il ne prend plus en main les grandes
décisions qu'il devait prendre il a
renoncé aux grandes réformes sur
lesquelles il s'est engagé
donc pour moi consolante c'est déjà le
passé c'est déjà le passé c'est un mort
vivant comme l'a dit nous y en a un
non non non non j'aime pas ta mère à ces
dégradations je pense qu'il est temps
qu'ils prennent de très grandes vacances
qui selon lui seront certainement très
mérité vous considérez que sa nouvelle
candidature serait tuner et fils qui
veut l'histoire du parti socialiste
avait la politique qu'il a menée la mnef
vassaux des bulles à mener avec
montebourg avec tous les autres et la
mnef macron qui règle juste m macron
aujourd'hui on a appris qu'il pourrait
très vite être candidat en tout cas
avant le 10 décembre
c'est pas mon logiciel politique mais je
trouve que ce serait un magnifique
adversaires au moins ils renouvellent le
paysage politique après c'est un libéral
qui s'assume
je préfère le libéralisme assumé d'un
maquereau ma libre alice trait à la
française un trait medef quand même on
en tapas aux rentes du medef donc on
tape au rang du nucléaire on tape on
rentre de la finance on t'a pas aux
rentes du bon donc je regrette qu'il ait
qui voit là mais c'est un libéral qui
s'assume hollande et valls se prétendent
des socialistes mais qu'ils font quand
même plutôt une politique libérale qui
s'assume pas je préfère quelqu'un qui
s'assume qui est nouveau dans le paysage
politique et ce sera encore une fois un
adversaire je crois de talent mais en
tous les cas c'est lui qui aurait pris
le moins de coups de votre part dans
cette émission passe alors qu'est-ce que
vous avez tapé sur la gomme et non mais
je te juger g vous savez je suis dans
une énorme frustration je suis dans une
énorme frustration on a un pays qui est
au bord de la rupture et on a un pays
qui pourrait basculer si vite parce que
l'agriculture qui fait du bien elle
existe les citoyens qui veulent protéger
leur santé ils sont déjà sensibilisés
les choix industriels
encore qu'ils créent de l'emploi
frustration c'est quoi mais parce que ce
pays ne ne se met pas en mouvement
autour de ses solutions à mars ne se met
pas non parce que sur verre pour un coût
macron sur l'écologie les nus regard ça
ah oui mais anglais il est nu avec mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que il ya
tellement de force vitale dans ce pays
qui font des choses magnifiques
si c'était à eux qu'ont laissé l'espace
et non pas ceux qui nous empêchent
d'avancer
ceux qui sont l'aîné des artisans du
conservatisme du corporatisme de la
rente et du blocage des institutions ce
qu'empêche le pays mais il il est là a
basculé potentiellement dans une
économie qui avance et dans une société
qui retrouve l'accompagnement vous
n'avez pas parlé d'alain juppé qui a eu
un engagement écologique fort quand
dernières années oui ça m'a pas marqué
dans les débats qu'ils ont organisé son
engagement pour l'environnement mais à
la primaire de droite sarkozy juppé vous
votez 2006 histoire c'est l'histoire de
la droite et du centre a pas échappé
même si certains électeurs de gauche
ah mais ça c'est le chacun est libre
dans son dans son choix et dans son
engagement
moi je suis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle pour les écologistes
mersa m'échapper d'avoir été avec nous
merci à j + 1 après votre désignation
tranquille munich merci beaucoup mais
quelle bonsoir à tous la semaine
prochaine c'est le sénateur bruno
retailleau qui sera notre invité qui est
un soutien fidèle lui de françois
s'agira juste après le rendu du tribunal
de nantes sa position effectivement sur
l'avenir de l'aéroport sera est
évidemment très attendu également à la
semaine prochaine